oh please no okay okay you have to do
this I've accepted it no please please
down the line please
what's up y'all so if you guys didn't
know I'm obviously a 15th degree black
belt in judo hamburgers and we have
these [ __ ] here we're going to
be I guess I guess I get they do martial
arts a little bit but they're gonna be
learning I don't know why you guys are
you're gonna teach me [ __ ] because I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm doing look
at this way that we are stretching dude
under the table tear forms no yeah you
want to see my form is for your food
let's see what you could do is Gary
Mesquite talking buddy let's do you do
suck I know your brother can do stuff
let's see you a quick [ __ ] whack this
was [ __ ] black dude oh you know what
he does for a living
[ __ ] nothing he does acts pretty [ __ ]
this Bulls hair basically though looking
at you teaching me how to kick ass and
apparently this guy's coming to I don't
even know what I'm doing he doesn't know
what is about what he's doing
I've been a martial artist for about 72
years now so - I'm about 83 years old so
just to let you know Asian don't raise
what the [ __ ] was that [ __ ] he should
not be able to do this so I'm surprised
the lens didn't crack at halfway you
hussy mine
[ __ ] hold on let me get my
stretch on real quick these basics you
guys not touching your toes first
whatever what do we call that what do we
call that tomato slice Evans's focus
just focus
how do you touch your penis to the floor
like that can you get down to this no
close that [ __ ] you don't get
why you got a bionic leg Akina - oh my
god why are you doing that because you
guys don't got breasts gravity in front
of you that's why I thought good if you
don't press Grampy oh my god thanks
eugenics he did he's got breast gravity
you decide Oh get it get it yeah so
often you should come look so we can
commit suicide all day Miyoshi and Peter
kind of took David - kind of like a
little stunt like action mini seminar
we're going to take him through some
basic stuff like basic training so hold
roles basic kicks and basic falls and
maybe some basic flips so we'll see more
roll baby
what just follow us follow oh you're
better on your right side right perhaps
we don't know that I don't should be
together okay put your feet together get
together all the way together okay okay
yeah your right side okay a little
bucket lesson is this [ __ ]
hey you're afraid of sharks right not
sure go check it out here on your right
side uh-huh
let's go to uni uh-huh so watching Eddie
well no entry scheduled on a cracker
okay look for my penis hey see that is
because my body is already circular so
naturally I roll you don't let a teacher
roller pull you how to roll right so
we're gonna do this all the way across
hold the wheel
yes just take your time so you don't get
diseases I'll go out to David I want to
see you do with your pretty eyes there
you know what we're more similar body
types like I see you do it you go okay
these graceful - oh don't push me doc
see that I've been doing this for 73 Oh
same thing that you did this way little
reverse it
okay so it'll either never go back I got
my back from back duty duty and do the
end okay I might take too much I'm good
oh my god don't ever be a father I think
he's more capable than he thinks I think
the biggest challenge for him is up here
you're gonna come down don't kick that
all the way up just get it off for what
drink your graceful man your way there's
a 103 better than me I know but imagine
religion has to see who's your buddy how
come you can move like that it doesn't
make sense Eve means better than me keep
defying physics again I'm looking a
while right
that should make no sense at all what
the [ __ ] oh god you know what
videogame we're good see what happened
was my titties moved forward and it
projected me over a little too much but
that's what happens when you like acid
to be able to just keep it up
oh my god that was a little too close
for comfort and I believe a lot of women
would like to be in my place but me on
the other hand actually was kind of so
roundhouse kick right just think of it
as three points okay one all right your
faces target once we lift the back foot
straight up to if you turn your hip
where your knee is in line with the
target and three now how do you balance
oh well you were there for like ten
seconds yup yep so now you're doing this
one two three I want you to do one two
okay so if I live yeah hey now now do it
like a man
almost like that huh hi I didn't want to
break your pad cuz it's a rental oh
shoot oh my head alright here's the
thing usually sheers the thing I need
you legs look this is what you're doing
Ezard lately i'm trying to be a raptor
here's what we want you to do close
insane he lost his [ __ ] mind
like I've been doing this for years I
lied I haven't been doing this for 72
years I've been doing for 72 seconds his
case were good his hands when he was
kicking was all like oh I'm kicking so
we're gonna sometimes you have to scare
master yeah how about we have to target
them okay I want the record to show I
moved it up every single time but he
just kept getting above it you know
what's happening I'm trying to kick him
in the face and like internally I want
to hurt him again it really must because
I want to kick him in the face
two steps one two very simple make sure
you want to like me chamber we call this
to reach chamber finish it you got the
[ __ ] with me
that's gonna be my face suit scream
drill he's not learning Korea hugs
okay let's teach Danielle Danielle
Danielle Danielle's talking a lot of
[ __ ] come on let's see a front kick
let's go hey put your face right there
so I'm doing this and I'm coming man
it's my right leg right that's
Danielle's face I'm getting ready there
it'll stop did it give me the address in
place
I [ __ ] up came to the wrong place you
fired oh it's working good good yes cuz
he's out he's learning - I'm learning
kicks nice put your face here are we
doing basically they've been doing
martial arts for roughly about ten years
but they've been doing it wrong so I'm
teaching them how to position their feet
in their hips so right now I specialize
in a specific type of martial art called
fat dumpling so now with that
Jack I think his strongest point was his
spinning hook kick it's like the most
advanced kick but I think he does the
best out of all the other kicks and also
like just as soon as he gets into the
groove like she's not she's not as bad
as he thinks he is up here I'm David I
think it's better than the oceans I
think I know see you have to be like a
teacup and a teapot you don't come to
the table with a teacup filled with
water at the table I think that's what
Bruce Lee said if you don't know he's
making within his wily stringing on the
condo profits we call that the under
suite whirlwind of the Guangzhou
province
nobody master this except for him
because most people die after after he
falls he steal your heart that's what he
does
he falls in love after he fall you fall
in love I don't know how you could use a
final retired if it doesn't hit somebody
to face you're basically right knee here
we go Vince he's going to show his [ __ ]
- I'm a cameraman today oh you don't
know beans was a great grand master of
something I have not figured out yet
this will got so many random [ __ ]
towns to the noise the [ __ ] out of me
after the kicks we were working on his
Falls just like basic reactions and
Falls we made them do some like low side
Falls and the power interval normal
reaction is if I do this you just throw
your neck that way and bring your back
right because if you were in a real
fight when you get hit your head comes
right now actually you I'll show you
what happen in a real fight you already
do it just take it well he's working on
his fall so that's good real fight I
don't know anybody in the history of
fighting
that's our stomach got back in they went
oh you think that her age I never heard
you I was your mother I'm your father oh
oh oh you got it that's it better
gentlemen are basically masters us in
about two minutes that's like the third
Balkan it's so much fun hitting with
this because I feel like I'm detached
from it so it doesn't hurt but it
actually hurts hello ha ha ha ha bring a
cop to [ __ ] we're doing the same thing
somebody's hitting in this way who shoot
boom boom I'll suck your dick for a
dollar I am me to [ __ ] your mom's bra
method acting I'm in character I'm a
degenerate
here's what you're doing next again see
he says steam so casually here's what
we're gonna do next
he was just kidding here's writing in
your nest that one that's better but
this is actually called the Power Ranger
fall it's when you see all those
explosions happen that it doesn't really
hit them
I do remember that in Power Rangers yes
we do that whatever a pencil fell they
just [ __ ] flew treaty no my pencil
I'm the retired puddy a little ooh so
show time I love this one last thing
what is it rose up before matches always
eight years old okay good so now you're
gonna do it you want to see first
yes of course I want to see it first but
you're gonna go into the pit home sorry
this is really bouncy a second of all
scared of heights
why did you do this to me what am i
doing
the point of the pro flip I just wanted
to see David get into the pit and try to
climb out first of all what the [ __ ]
watching David in the foam pit was it
was sad it was like seeing one of those
like hamsters stuck in like gravies just
like yeah hey can we do that again on a
fan hit slow motion I was wondering when
he would figure out that I was just
messing with him I'm [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah out of it so what we learned today
is that this man right here is a good
haha this slowly the one of the most
difficult living out loud episodes are
done really yes really
maybe really really and why do you jump
so high for somebody here sighs you
don't make any sense at all yeah I was
looking for the strings I was like ooh
matrix
you're so Manhattanville oh you like it
yeah and you talk like bowl of douchey
pages you break my record knife in your
back break my record now I break you why
are you broken anywhere good you're
doing it right
where this doesn't please me from this
wall those [ __ ]